hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have requested already it was
played yesterday on sami stream
and it's a game featuring uh the
legendary indian stand-up comedian uh
slash streamer
samarana and of course the reigning
world champion magnus carlsen it
took place some uh almost at the end of
summer stream
uh and uh it was a blitz game but not an
actual blitz game it was more of a
more of a bill gates challenge type of
blitz game where magnus allowed his time
to run out uh
until he had 15 seconds on the clock i i
think he also had 15 seconds against the
bill gates so it's uh three mi three
minutes for
uh some i end only 15 seconds for magnus
so a good
a good idea here would be maybe to play
a sort of a defensive opening really
just try and protect your king and
basically try and flag magnus
uh in those 15 seconds but uh let's see
what actually happened in the game some
i opened with e4
and here he issued a dare to magnus he
said uh something uh
something like i dare you to play e5
here in magnus said okay
i'm gonna play e5 he played d5 and then
samai replied with
f4 like i said it would be a good idea
to play some sort of a defensive opening
but he he wouldn't be uh be much of a
comedian if he
didn't try to make the most of this
opportunity so he went for the
well almost the the greatest opening of
all the kings gambit there are some
better gambits as
you you might have heard uh but here
magnus
just allowed his clock to uh go uh to 15
seconds and then he started playing so
bishop to c5 this is what magnus goes
for
uh he doesn't accept the gambit rather
he wants to get some rapid development
in
and as it usually is when you have 15
seconds on the clock i don't know if
you've ever tried playing with 15
seconds on the clock
uh almost every move will be a pre move
uh until
well until you reach at least some some
part of the
middle game so here semi-continued
development knight to f3 and here
d5 sort of like a postponed fault beerus
gambit
uh where you will either capture an e5
or you're gonna go e captures on d5 some
i captured on d5 and magnus uh
most likely pre-moved e4 so the knight
is under attack and here magnus of
course is expecting e5 however uh
some i tricked him as magnus uh
pre-moved knight to f6 but somebody went
to d4
and here uh magnus pre-moved knight to
f6 as
and as this move doesn't really make all
that much sense uh it is already as of
move five that we have a completely new
game
and here some i could get a lot of
activity in for example if knight e5
uh then uh magnus would really really be
in trouble because he still has to react
to his bishop being under attack
uh this doesn't work this check just c3
and the black doesn't
gain any tempe uh so just measure back
to b6 and now you can do a lot of things
you can go bishop b5
check you can defend this pawn with with
c4
it would be tough however someone went
for a nice trade with the d
captures on c5 he just wanted to trade
we have e captures on f3 and semi
recaptures queen captures on f3 and the
magnus castles king's side
uh summer's king is still in the center
of the board and the magnus doesn't have
time for some sort of a long
end game if he if he traded queens he of
course just wants to
checkmate some ice king that's still in
the center of the board
so samai of course does the correct
thing he he plays bishop to d3 he wants
to castle his king to safety
and magnus prevents this for the moment
he goes rook to e8
check and here this is not a problem uh
often times when you play the king's
gambit there are some very nice
lines where you even allow queen to h4
check or even bishop to h4 check
where you will play king to f1 for
example later on you can play king 2f2
and then you're going to bring the rook
into the game
however here some i played bishop to e3
and
this will be uh this will be a big
problem for summer
as uh well now now this uh this is now
something that magnus can really uh sing
his teeth into so here
bishop to g4 first attacking some ice
queen
queen to g3 and now knight captures on
d5 just adding
another uh attacker here uh offering
this
uh this bishop here for for the uh for
the bishop on e3 so you could even you
could either go for queen captures
or you could move the king or you could
do what some i did which is
h3 but h3 is a bit of a problematic uh
issue because magnus just plays knight
captures on e3
and now you can't really capture this
because if pawn captures then just
knight f5
check and you lose the queen so not not
an option for somewhere so sami goes
king to f2
he gets away from any nasty discoveries
but now comes queen to d4 for magnus now
threatening again all sorts of nasty
discoveries and
there just isn't all that much you can
do here whatever you do you you're just
going to lose you can't kick the queen
away if c3 then the bishop hangs
so you have to give up something some i
played rook to e1
but now it's actually a forced checkmate
uh in seven
uh with with best with best defense from
semi so feel free to pause the video
here and uh
checkmate semi while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well a forced
mating sequence in seven and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's knight to f5 with check just a nice
discovered check
also connecting with the queen so here
uh rook the rook to e3 is the most
resilient defense but it doesn't matter
it only prolongs the mate for two moves
so here some i gave up the queen just
right away we have rook captures an
uh e3 rook captures and the queen
captures on e3
uh only one more move left for semi king
to f1 and now
magnus finished the game with knight the
g3 checkmate
uh so really nice checkmate the queen
prevents the king from escaping the
knight delivers check
and that's uh that's a very nice uh
a nice queen knight combo and it's very
interesting that uh out of those 15
seconds that magnus started with
he ended the game with 8.2 seconds on
the clock so it took magnus
uh less than seven seconds to play uh
this entire game
now uh like i said uh you you should you
should definitely go for some sort of a
defensive approach and try and try and
hold off but uh some i
bravely went uh like like uh
braves to robin and uh you know he
wasn't afraid of anything and he just
took magnus head on uh but then then
then this happened
uh and also after after the stream some
i tweeted something so here is a tweet
from
he thanked everyone for joining the
stream and he says that
he had the most beautiful time of
quarantine and learned that
king's gambit is the worst opening now
i'm sure that
it was a very enjoyable stream and that
he had a wonderful time but
i must urge you uh the king's gambit is
not
the worst possible opening there are way
worse openings and
uh you should you should play it you're
going to have fun with it and
most of the times when you play it good
things will happen
uh so yeah that's the game uh like i
said a lot of you have requested it so
i thought it was a good idea to show or
show it
i do hope you enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank nathan and lauren lanier
uh vinash p bart carpenter tom hayton to
wait
and derek von morik for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the st
louis event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend
and if you want to check out the uh
original footage of this uh
game being played the link will be the
first thing you see in the description
below
uh see you soon